well hello this is danielle dimartino
booth
with your next installment of down the
middle with d martino booth i'm
delighted
today to have peter atwater join me
um outside of being a great twitter
buddy of mine which
who isn't uh he runs financial insights
a consulting firm and he is uh teaches
economics
at william mary college in williamsburg
and before we get to that because i'm so
fascinated
about the world of economics and
academia
because i was kind of thrown into it
working at the federal reserve not
knowing i was going to be thrown into it
but before we get there i always like to
go back to people's childhoods and
i'm going to start a little bit later in
yours because
you somehow ended up growing up
in new jersey and graduating from high
school in
paris france and i'm not quite sure how
that works
so why don't we start there sure it
works pretty easy when your dad gets
transferred
as you're finishing your junior year in
high school and so
um you know a little bit of gnashing of
teeth you know do i stay do i go
you know we were looking at different
options and i'm really glad we went
um you know it's pretty cool you know
going to high school in paris
you know particularly i grew up in a
fairly rural part of new jersey
and so to go from that where everything
was 20 minutes a half hour away by car
topping on the metro i mean we would all
meet friday nights
at the top of the metro is stopped by
the arctic triomphe
and then you'd go do whatever
um and it was a blast oh my gosh i mean
i it would to me
it would be like being on a field trip
every day
yeah and you you know your sports teams
you know where you're playing local high
schools in new jersey
they would be playing the american
school in milan the american school in
in london the american school in in the
hague and so
you go all over europe just sort of as
if it were normal for everybody
and was that typical american football
you were playing i was not playing
american
what was the sport a little bit of
volleyball but mostly just going along
i would have done the same thing and
they could have told me it was bowling
and i've been like if we're going to hey
i'm on so that's pretty amazing
so um obviously you you picked up french
i did
is that something you had to well yeah
it's a fairly uh levian vocabulary that
i have it's you know
shopping and buying food and you know
just getting around but yeah i can
i can get myself out of trouble if i
have to and probably a younger
drinking age i'm not sure why i'm
thinking of that but i'm just
you'd have to think that europeans would
be a little bit more relaxed than
than americans there was no drinking age
as i recall
so yeah it was it was quite interesting
going from
you know sneaking six packs to um just
you know have a good time at the cafe so
uh did you think about staying in europe
for your college studies what brought
you back to the united states
so i always plan to come back to the us
for college
um and you know a lot of people said
why didn't you do a junior year abroad
and you know honestly
being there for for summers being there
for different breaks um you know i
didn't
see the need to do that sure you know i
did hope for at some point to have a
overseas assignment um with work but
that never happened
and that's okay so um what i what i
really want to know
about william and mary is the whole jon
stewart thing
however i'm also kind of a history buff
and uh in one of my recent weeklies
i studied the history and the founding
of harvard university
so in studying up on you i found out
that
if we're talking about a combination of
king william iii
king mary queen mary the second i'm
watching i'm i'm i'm watching
i'm watching too much netflix trust me
when i say when it comes to the crown
these days so this is all so fascinating
to me
but i think i've got it written down
right a a letter
a letters patent so i might be putting
you on the spot but
what the heck is a letters patent and
how does it coming from england
end up founding the second oldest school
in america
16 1693 amazing 1693
yeah so george with and others convinced
the crown
to set up a college here in the us u.s
and this was a time that the crown was
being incredibly
um charitable if you look at a lot of
the hospitals in
london for example um they sort of date
from the same era
of benevolence and so
there was a sense you know let's let's
educate these
these these folks so far and yeah
william and mary second oldest college
in in the country
um and it's it's wild
place because it's a sits at the end of
colonial williamsburg
so the ren building sits as one bookend
and on one side you have all of these
folks pressed in 18th century garb
they're all doing recreation
and on the other side of the building
there's this huge field where
on any given day you'll see people
throwing a frisbee
playing catch basking in the sun
right right it's really hard fun well
okay so this is a question you might not
have the answer to but i'm just it's
it's
it's just a burning in in the back of my
head is
did williamsburg precede the college or
was williamsburg named
after the college that's a great
question i know isn't it yeah all right
so you're gonna have to tweet you're
gonna have to tweet out the answer
and i and i have a few folks that i know
who will know that answer so
yeah i will let you know because i would
think i mean
you when you think of new york and i
mean all of these things that were
new were just new in the new world um
okay let's get to what i really want to
know jon stewart you were his r.a
yeah freshman already um yeah
they're first gates for south uh yeah
john
was a soccer player he actually played
on the varsity soccer team
and you know i think all of us are
amazed
you know he was he was fighting and
sarcastic even then
so i just give him huge props for
finding a way to monetize it
as well as he did living the dream yeah
very smart guy very smart um so
you studied economics in college was
that
did you know you were going that route
no i started off as a
physics major my dad's an engineer and
so
it was very clear that whatever i
majored in
needed to result in the job and
i took a freshman econ class having to
fulfill
various requirements
had a great professor and i can remember
going home
raising the topic with my parents over
an awkward
christmas dinner about the fact that i
was going to switch and become an
economy
sort of what are you going to do with
that being the response unfortunately
is it okay so okay so
i get the econ part um but you didn't go
off into economics
after that was was what what
what drew you to what
we think of as a conventional bank but
you'd be hard-pressed to find anybody
right now
who could envision j.p morgan as being
a conventional bank because we think of
it as the bank that is now bigger than
goldman sachs the big investment
bank but what drew you to jp morgan and
why not economics to start off other
than the fact that economists don't make
very much
so i've never thought of myself as an
academic
um i was i was more interested in sort
of the applied aspects of
economics money and banking and
international
finance and
you know going to the american school
there were lots of
children of parents who worked at
different banks
in paris and so names like
morgan guarantee first bank of boston
there were there were lots of names
and thinking at some point if i wanted
to get back to
europe working for a bank it i was
looking for
a bank that had international experience
and that's what
really drew me to work then morgan
guarantee
right right right so you started
in 83 and i think
of because i'm a big student of the
subprime crisis
i always think of the early 80s
as kind of the advent of credit in u.s
households kind of
we were kind of headed towards the
yuppie era
but this is really when the baby boomer
generation
adopted started to embrace credit
so you got you you had a front
row with popcorn view to this evolution
of the us consumer talk to me about it
yeah so
i i consider myself one of the luckiest
people
in terms of timing you know right place
at the right time
yeah you know to your point this is the
beginning of the democratization of
consumer credit
and so you have banks interested in
credit cards car loans home equity loans
lots of mortgage credit and
i started jp morgan working in a group
called the
asset finance group which was
working with folks like sears trying to
figure out how do you help them
to raise credit back by their credit
card receivables
you're doing the same thing with four
doing the same thing with gm
wait is that like factoring well in
a traditional sense yes but not for a
company like
order jammer or
it was more how do you find a cheap way
for them to raise capital against their
loans okay and and so we're doing
all of this work trying to understand
the portfolio characteristics the
payment rates default rates
and essentially setting in motion
the asset-backed securities business you
know securitization
and what was fascinating you know it was
frustrating initially because we're
doing all this work and then you'd see
first boston
land a deal for gm and you're like we
can do the same thing we just didn't
have the underwriting powers
right and at that point
there was then this ground swell among
the banks particularly folks like city
who are like look
we have all these assets why should we
have to hire
first boston solomon to underwrite
assets that are on our balance sheet and
because those are those
those were some big those were where the
fees were those were
where the fees were and and so it was a
big
push with the fed to let the banks
get into the underwriting business but
in a way that the fed thought was safe
so first thing commercial paper
you know essentially you know banks have
been doing bankers acceptances for
since the beginning of time commercial
paper was a natural
add-on and then they said let's do asset
back securities
and so within moments we pivoted from
put it on our balance sheet to package
it and sell it off
so this would have been around the same
time
as rainery coming up i
i think now i'm going to put my own foot
in my mouth but i think this is also
when
kind of the when mortgages were changing
the way that they were packaged
oh yeah yeah i mean louie um you know
larry fink you don't think of him
in that position now but his his roots
were
in first boston's passive back business
building its mortgage
franchise wow the things we don't know
um so i know that you
study behavior a lot um but i want to
stay with this kind of
era if you will for a little while um
did you get to see how
credit or the access to credit changed
consumers
behavior kind of as a factor of time
absolutely um you know you saw
particularly in the in the
auto space where it
went from you know saving up for a car
having a down payment to a car to
financing all of the car so it
transformed it from a
you know capital intensive what's the
price of the car
issue two what's the monthly payment on
the car
and so we essentially changed the
consumer's
mindset in the same way the mortgage
industry did for housing
nobody nobody really cares that much
about the cost of the house
it's what's the monthly payment on the
house
i think i was way too influenced by my
mother growing up with
her grandparents who were kind of
scarred by
the first depression early on in the
1900s and then the great depression
because
i still look at price um i've never
bought anything on credit and i've only
had a mortgage for a few years and i
couldn't sleep while i did
but on the other hand i worked at the
federal reserve for a few years and
that'll
that'll give you all kinds of um uh
but speaking of the federal reserve so
you were also
uh you were you were there jaden working
for for 13 years
you were there when alan greenspan got
his start
in the business so
what um i'm curious director of
jp morgan i did not
yeah yeah when i first joined he was on
the board
how cozy well you know i've always
wondered where his obsession with the
stock market came from
because when he was chairman
of the federal reserve every morning
when he got to his office he would he he
needed his overnight what happened in
the equities
world on his desk his briefing and in
his biography
it goes into the fact that that
completely shaped
his tenure at the fed and he actually
takes away from himself that this
happened he
considers it to be one of his faults but
anyways we could go off on that
that tangent all day long so um
so take
so you left well
first of all there's a story there and
um
and i actually want to ask you about
not just the moment and you can tell the
story
but also how moments change
us and because we all have one
but tell us first about your moment
i'm sorry when you decided to make a
complete you know
turn in your life and say okay this is
it it's it's time to make a change
so so i'm turning 45
and i'm getting ready to blow out the
candles on the cake true story
and my son looks at me and at that point
he was eight and he looks at me and he
says dad you're halfway to 90.
and you know you you talk about one of
those
you know sort of gut-wrenching punches
it's like
yeah i am yeah and
i didn't i sort of concluded at that
point
if i didn't want to keep doing what i
was doing
um didn't know entirely what i wanted to
do next
but it was it was a moment of i need to
stop
doing what i'm doing and i give my wife
enormous credit for insisting that if i
made the decision that i was going to
make
to stop that i not commit to anything
for a year she said i know you
you're going to stop and somebody's
going to call you in two weeks and say
i've got this great opportunity over
here why don't you come do it and you're
going to say yes
and so i had to just not
do something for a year
which for a type a like me is was really
hard
i can only imagine and in
amidst that one of the things that i was
quite passionate about still in
was financial literacy and
my wife found this article about this
website that was focused on financial
literacy called minionville
founded by now a very dear friend of
mine todd harrison
and so i'm looking online
and this is 2005 2006.
and i'm watching people writing about
consumer credit
and i'm like no no no i
that's not exactly how this works and so
initially i approached todd to say i'm
happy to contribute
not sure what i'm going to do next but i
can i do it anonymously
and so we used the pseudonym minion
peter for
probably 18 months two years but the
more i started to
write the the more
i got questions from people about
well what else what did i think of this
what did i think of that
and you know going into 2007
i found myself advising
a small group of hedge funds some money
managers
helping them to prepare for what would
become the financial crisis
that it was it was obvious having spent
my career in securitization having been
a bank treasurer had worked with the
rating agencies
you know i you couldn't have picked a
better crisis for me
sure but you presumably saw
all of this coming yeah
yeah tragically so i mean if
anyone looking in any direction i mean
it wasn't just that the overconfidence
was in one place
it was in every place that the whole
entourage
was convinced that housing prices only
went up
oh yeah i mean i mean we
evolved to so to speak at the same time
because i was writing about the housing
crisis when i was
um asked to join the federal reserve um
and the
running joke was that they hired me to
shut me up because i was writing these
awful things about people taking all
this money out of their homes and
um but i mean it was surreal
to join the fed because at the when you
walked in the door you're like okay the
gig is up right you guys
are kidding right everybody there
believed
everything that greenspan and then
bernanke said that home prices could
only go up
and you know we didn't know until years
later that alan greenspan's dissertation
which was buried in a basement somewhere
was on housing bubbles
so he knew kind of what was you know
happening on his watch janet yellen
you know famously was it the san
francisco fed
at the time and and and didn't see
it coming either but what was um
in your view because i i get questions
about this all the time you know
that the fed caused the housing crisis
the the banks caused the housing crisis
run us through all the players i
i think everyone was culpable
and that's the nature of saturating
overconfidence
is that whether it's within a company
like boeing
you know in the in the days and weeks
before those crashes
in in a economy more broadly
everybody succumbs
and it and it's you know chemicals in
our brain
it's the crowd effect of wanting to fit
in with our peers
the factors are numerous but we all were
guilty
you know we took the loans we shouldn't
have they gave us the loans we shouldn't
they shouldn't have given us you know so
you can
kick every box and and
and your comment about trying to find
the culpable
individual you know is sort of what
steered me
into the work that i do today which is
let's let's
look at the behaviors horizontally
let's look at what is what are people
doing in common
because that comment out that common
experience
is going to tell us everything we need
to know
about how the crowd feels
and so i you know i think
the crowd was guilty um and it was
guilty at the top
and it was equally guilty at the bottom
of then being far too pessimistic
everybody felt in 2009 that it was just
going to get worse
regulators policy makers individuals
homeowners
everybody in the lot so so to me
the guilt is exists in both ends of the
spectrum
so i'm dying to get where we are today
but but i can't i have to wait
go back to minionville for a minute just
because i i want to commiserate
or i want to enjoy it with you or live
vicariously
i mean when i got away from compliance
it was like
breathing oxygen for the first time what
what
what were those what were those eighteen
months when you were writing another
anonymously i mean i could only i know
what i felt
how did it feel um
you know i had never thought of myself
that you know
at that point you know the blogger you
know writing
something and and my my mindset danielle
was
how can i be helpful to people you know
i
i don't want people to be misled by
all of the noise and to be able to see
in a way that was not you know
followed i wasn't trying to throw gas on
a fire but more
trying to help folks to navigate what
was clearly going to be a difficult time
and not to get swept up did we learn our
lesson
as as households as consumers
in the aftermath of that subprime
crisis for a little while
yes but we are an
optimistic animal and
we easily like the next bright shiny
thing
[Music]
and i think in fairness to the consumer
in this cycle
there was a lot of seduction
um being thrown out by policymakers
in the form of free money
and so i i can't blame
consumers in this case what stuns me
you know is that the adults in the room
corporate treasurers today
are the you know home flippers
of 2005. they
they swallowed the debate
and you know have
over levered the what i call the last
balance sheet
and the last balance sheet available was
the big corporation and
we have trashed them
so so so let let's talk about this
because this is
um you know i've done i've been looking
at at the powell era
uh and we don't we don't realize it and
i i was looking at the
continuum because i was i was saying
just
yesterday i was i was writing about 2020
and
it being the largest growth in
global debt ever and i looked back
and i got the data and it's not
it's not 2007. was the biggest year for
global debt
growth and that was of course when our
mortgage market was its biggest still
still the biggest debt market in the
world and then
speaking of powell 2017
now 2017 you had global quantitative
easing
the run rate was over two trillion
dollars that year
and then
he took office february the 4th 2018.
and this is when europe was
tapering this is when the united states
was not engaged in quantitative easing
and this is when a very sober and
determined
jay powell was going to normalize
interest rates and shrink that balance
sheet
by golly and it was as if somebody
flipped a switch on him
and so i i've been you know
valmagette in the volatility incident in
in february i mean his first day in
office the dow jones was down
more than a thousand points and he said
nothing
uh but then you you got towards
halloween
speaking of balance sheets and halloween
we had
the debt of general electric downgraded
and then issuance froze and
powell has since evolved shall we say
speaking of swinging from one end of the
spectrum to another but
talk to me about
the adults in the room and those cfos
and what's happened in the space of the
last
decade in corporate america
so i think that they reach a point where
they've grown in size that
the game of mergers becomes more
challenging
and remember that this has been a
culture of
bi eviscerate by eviscerate
by buy eviscerate so so
growth through destruction of the
operating costs of what it was that you
require peter
they call that synergy they use a much
more polite term
or as they said it excellently you know
recently you know
culling which i thought was just
just horrific um but
i think that where where you ended up
was the only way to grow
earnings per share in order to meet
rising expectations of the analyst
community was
financial engineering and with
free money you could financially
engineer
whatever eps you wanted for the next
six quarters and and we did
corporate america you know this buyback
game
the whatever it is
[Music]
to achieve these results and
and i don't think folks really
appreciate
that that one of the tenets of
this post-banking crisis
era and you're seeing it even more in
was size
gave you access
that the simplicity of the
mindset today is if you are big
you are rich you get credit
you get access to the equity market you
get whatever you want
and you know we can you know drill down
on the role of the rating agencies
play in this but but i think that
that the environment has
so advantaged the big and the mighty
that they have become lazy
and really have no sense
of what it would mean to manage a
true economic cycle without the fed
without fiscal stimulus without
any of the the training wheels that have
kept the bicycle upright
in the past decade yeah i mean just to
take but one example i'm not picking on
them i mean i like a movie as much as
the next guy
but you know when i was looking at amc's
financials they've been running up debt
at a faster pace than they've had
operating income
for four years now so
i mean that's one of my pet peeves
and boy do i i should really stay off
twitter at night but anyways but one of
my pet peeves
is that they call it the coronavirus
recession
it's it's not because this is this has
been coming this has been building
for a long time and but but my question
to you is
so in the subprime crisis you kind of
saw what was coming
and you can also see what was coming
today we've displaced the household with
the us corporate um and it's not on bank
balance sheets it's all over the capital
markets
but can you see what's coming today
yeah yeah you can um
you know that the manias are are obvious
around us
you know you you can whether it's you
know bitcoin mania
spac mania ev mania
esg mania you know
there's there's this collective
enthusiasm you know all the space travel
stuff
um we have this this classic
futuristic mindset that
whether it's communication
transportation technology you know the
payment space to me may be the
most egregious um
but but yeah you can see where the
excesses are
they're in plain sight and they're where
everybody has made the most money
believing that the most
money is yet to come
so as as somebody who is
still suffering from post-traumatic
stress syndrome from working inside the
fed for nine years
um i want i'm going to jump to my very
last question right now
which is totally against the rules but
here we are
another peter friend of mine peter
buckvar has always maintained that
that what we're in right now is a
confidence bubble
and as long as people have confidence in
the power of the central banks
everything's going to be fine so
what shakes this confidence because
i i mean when you consider what was done
on march the 23rd
which by the way jay powell was prepared
for
after general electric got downgraded i
mean that was a plan that the fed had in
place
in the event of a black swan but i was
listening to
jim chanos get interviewed about being
short tesla for the last five years
i don't even know how he's still
standing even though he's probably the
savviest you know
short man on on the street but
what can shake this confidence in the
fed
so let's let's talk about confidence and
effect sure
so in in the work that i trust that i do
i try to
sit step back and say okay what would be
a
useful barometer an objective
measuring stick for confidence
in x so if i'm looking at a company
i'm going to look at the stock price
because that to me is a great barometer
of
of confidence and management confidence
in the product confidence in
whatever it is so i can look every day
people debate this price rise but with
confidence there's confidence for stock
i don't i don't care it's a
it's an equalizer sure it's just a way
to
look and assess so then i say okay for
the fed
what would be a good proxy for
confidence in the fit
so i step back and i say so when was
const when did confidence in the feds
suck
when were people viewing the fed as
incumbents
well you go back to the late 70s early
80s right
and you say okay so what what stands out
well to me interest rates stand out
interest rates were spiking and so i
step
in and i say okay let's say
interest rates are a measure of fed
confidence
in inverse relationships so you could
say the price of bonds
because but and so
i then say okay the low in confidence
for the fed was
1980 19 so now i'm looking at the tenure
when did rates bottom
well first time they bought them was
what 2014.
i've got my dates right
and you'll notice something really
interesting
what happened when rates started to rise
just after that
well okay i'm going to let you tell me
but i'm then i'm going to hit my head
like i had like i needed a v8 and now
i'm going to take notes pimco
the world's biggest bond manager
imploded
and the king of bonds essentially is
exited from the scene bill gross
leaves so i step back and say
yeah interest rates
are a great proxy for
confidence in the fed
in fixed income money managers
in the credit community
more broadly
so i look at this and say
confidence in the fed will remain
so long as interest rates are managed
in this low bound
but when they start to move up
the system is inherently very very
fragile
it's going to be 1980 in reverse
because we are as overconfident today
as we were under confident four years
ago
right they were inept now they're
omnipotent today and omnipotence
to me is always always
the end and we believe
the system believes central banks are
omnipotent
and there is inherent fragility to that
that i don't think
is being reflected in valuations of
anything
and to be clear i don't wish policy
makers
a demise i you know i appreciate that
they have to go to work and do what they
do
but we are at a point where the system
believes in them
in a unhealthy way and
they can't taper without having
a terrible temperature no i mean
we just walk through what you know the
biggest you know 2017 and what has
happened since then
and you know i think
i i think to your point i think that we
will all
remember and it's not just me being
bitter on twitter because i wrote
half a book about janet yellen but i
think we will all remember
when janet yellen took over at treasury
and when the last time we had a labor
economist
at treasury which was headed into the
70s
um so
so here's so many behavioral parallels
to the 1970s beyond
you know social parallels cultural
parallels
this is this is a clear
social mood echo so let's bring the
coronavirus
into this dynamic because there is
there is a real economy out there
somewhere
and there really are a lot of americans
who are not working
and you know speaking of big small
is being eviscerated right now the small
business in america
is i mean the numbers you read you you
see some of the survey data that
48 of small businesses aren't sure that
they can survive the fourth quarter of
2020 you're like that
has to be a typo um
and that's what this is where i get
caught up in the inflation debate
because rising interest rates to me
is as you say and by the way this is a
huge light bulb
i'm going to get the transcript of the
interview and then you're going to
become a whole weekly and everybody's
going to
get to read every word you're saying
but to me rising interest rates
as especially as the street views them
is a sign of confidence in the
economy but in the 1970s
we had rising interest rates and we
didn't have such good economic
growth at the same time and yet people
tend to talk about inflation or
deflation
they never talk about the stag in the
middle
so i'm curious where you are on this
spectrum because
there is something real going on in the
u.s economy right now
wall street wants to get past it wall
street is ready to wall street has
declared that we're in recovery i doubt
the good people at the national bureau
of economic research would agree with
them
but wall street has declared that we're
in the free and the clear and that we're
at the advent of a whole new bull market
yeah scorching i saw the word last night
oh boy
yeah i mean wall street is convinced
that post
vaccine there is you know the sky is
clear as far as you can see
you know i think that we've seen
a significant low in the commodity space
you know i i look at you know corporate
write-offs like the one
exxon took as a as a capitulatory act
those are things that only happen you
know at
very lows and confidence and so
i don't know if we've got one more leg
down or not but
but somewhere around here is a major low
in the commodity space more broadly
and so to your point the potential for
high inflation low growth in the united
states i think is really high
um particularly
low earnings growth because
we there's a societal swing that's now
underway
towards wage growth
and so there i think that you're going
to see
more and more states enacting minimum
wage
hikes you're going to see a
a big swing from a pressure standpoint
away from the shareholder to labor
the sense that if shareholder
maximization went way too far
and so you're going to have
internal pressure on wages
that put pressure on on the bottom line
companies will be unable to grow
earnings at the rate they expect
and at the same time it will be socially
unacceptable
to slash employment in the united states
to remedy that situation
interesting so
based on your thesis
companies won't be able the reaction
function won't be
what it once was because when you read
words like calling
you turn on the screen and you see that
the stock is way up
and that's kind of still the world we
live in
but to see that change and you could
certainly see
that shift in and you can feel it in the
political winds
for sure yeah and i
and i see it you know when i started
writing about the k-shaped recovery
i never expected it to gain attraction
that it would become part of the
vernacular
and that's significant to me as a
researcher because it says
people get that people know exactly what
that means
even if they don't and what that means
is the divide between the haves and the
have-nots has grown too wide
and so something is going to press
the two back together i would love to
think
that those at the top will enable those
at the bottom to rise up
graciously but i'm not convinced that
that's likely to happen
but i think that the divide has become
so
simple to explain through the letter k
then it's going to now close
yeah you know it was interesting um
because i i've had people ask me all the
time you know why
why can't we explain to the layperson
the influence the fed has had on
increasing the inequality divide
and my because i'm i'm i'm right there
with you when it comes to financial
literacy i think it's
it's critical to saving capitalism
i'm not there's no hyperbole there um
but what's what's intriguing to me and
i'd love to know
your thoughts is what are the french
thinking
i mean we're burning our own businesses
we're looting our own stores
the french went to go burn down the bonk
de france
so i mean are they more enlightened
how do we how do how does the public
finally get their head around who the
player is
in the background so
you know i don't know what the trigger
will be
and and but i think that yeah i think
i think the fed is very vulnerable to
this kind of
social backlash that you're talking
about
but perceives itself to be so
abstract and so behind the scenes that
nobody would come at them
well they believe in their benevolence
they truly believe in their benevolence
they
yeah they they believe in the wealth
effect they believe in trickle down
i mean you've got prima facie evidence
staring them in the face and they still
believe and and that's it's interesting
because you're inside of
academics and so you have a bird's eye
view in a way
to how heavy of an influence
academics has been in the field of
not economics per se because i think of
you i think of william white i think of
gary schilling i mean it's not economics
per se
but boy has it had an influence on
monetary policy making
yeah and corporate policy i mean you
look at
shareholder maximization you know coming
right out of
the 1960s textbook so
so i feel that economic
theory is right for
another massive transition
where we throw out the bones
if you were reading you know chicago
school economics
50 years ago somebody and i don't know
who that somebody is
but somebody's going to be the next
kings who says
that was wrong and be believed
and be believed and be believed
you know i think a lot of people think
that person is stephanie kelton
um i i
have a lot of respect for her but i
think that
the whole notion of modern monetary
theory
only exists in an environment where
interest rates are the historical lows
if interest rates start to rise that
whole mindset
becomes really suspect and i think
that uh to your point uh
and again i'm gonna go back to janet
yellen because i think that this is
a moment in history because if you think
about modern monetary theory
you have to reopen the federal reserve
act
you cannot have one without the other
you have to have the fed be able to
formally buy
treasuries at auction in order to truly
set up mechanistically helicopter money
and that is i i'm dear friends with
lacey hunt
and he's been right for so long but you
asked him the one thing in the world
that could make interest rate rise
interest rates rise and that's if you
reopen the federal reserve act
and you allow the mechanism to be put in
place and
and then then you get inflation then you
get inflation
and and and to kelton's point
you're not going to have a congress say
okay well
we've got inflation so we're just going
to come together quickly and pass
legislation
quickly that says we're going to raise
income tax rates
it just won't fly no and the higher
interest rates go that the more
fiscal stimulus comes off oh
and and i mean you can't even apply
that the notion of higher interest rates
to how levered our economy is
there the divide is too wide you can't
even bring you can't bring the
you can't have a commercial a
conversation about commercial real
estate
and rising interest rates something
would blow up in between it's just it
doesn't work
it doesn't work when you think about the
two trillion dollars that corporations
have added
since march um
let's let's shift gears for a minute
because i'm so
intrigued in america right now
uh about the coronavirus
and not so much the political
aspect of it how masks have been
politicized
not so much that but why people
approach it so differently
and because from my perch in texas
you'd never know you would never know
that there are record
deaths and record hospitalizations and
people are just going about their
business
and but i'm i'm curious about the idea
of fatigue having set in
and what you think has happened in
in the mindset since the advent of this
crisis so if i
look at the drop in march
you had a profound collapse in
confidence
evidenced by google searches for the
word unprecedented
and so the sense that nothing makes
sense
today immense uncertainty
and an immense sense of powerlessness
and we don't think of the opposite of
confident as vulnerable
but it is um it's
if there's a there's an element of
control
confidence is certainty and control
together
and when we don't have confidence we
don't have certainty
and we don't have a control and so
there was this this incredible
vulnerability
that existed and you saw
people decide at that point almost this
wild wild west mindset of
how do i regain certainty how do i
regain
control and you saw
two models one was a model that said
we will regain certainty and control if
we reopen the economy
and so what you've seen is some portion
of the population
that went hell bent on reopening the
economy
be damned don't need masks we're just
gonna
we're just going to plow through this i
live there
another segment of the economy said i
will regain
certainty and control by hybrid
by going into quarantine and just
you know block up the walls close
everybody out
i will be safe in my own space
with very few people and if i have to go
out into that world
i'm going to wear masks and shields and
gloves and spray and
and so both of those to me
are very clear and
deliberate attempts on our part to
regain a sense of certainty and control
they run in conflict to each other
but that's the nature of what happens
in lows and confidence you know there
are
i actually think there are five
different responses you know
fight and flight get two you know
the ones that come to mind but you also
have freeze
you have follow
and you have feed um
yeah we we will gorge ourselves in those
moments
that's why we reach for the ben and
jerry's ice cream
and to me it's also not been a surprise
that you've seen
some americans fight
you know the black lives matter you have
lots of social dynamics going on
you have some who are frozen in space
and they're quarantined
you have others who are following
leaders
you know it's not a surprise again in
those moments of low confidence that
you would see an authoritarian like
leader like donald trump
gaining intense popularity
amid the environment um
and so you have all of these you know
people baking bread that's the feed
aspect of it but i think that
from my perspective we're seeing a
pretty clear response that doesn't seem
abnormal in conflict with each other
absolutely but
that's the nature of these chaotic
moments
is people lose confidence
in the institutions and the norms that
held us together
and we become pioneers in the wilderness
and what do we do now some go out some
stay in so
everybody plays it their way and that's
that's
that's my take on what's happened this
year
is there anything that can shift
the mindset back if the virus gets bad
enough or do we just
have we decided the path and we're gonna
take it people have decided their path
and are going to take it
um so there will be a large population
for whom
the vaccine is a no-go
well we did hear it be called the trump
vaccine which i found to be
2020's most ironic moment because that
is
what would get people who would
typically not want to take the vaccine
to take the vaccine
i mean that's the world we live in as
you describe it
the the need to follow
and i think that in many ways that is
where we are also because of this lack
of financial literacy
so i think there's a large swath of the
population
that needs to be led um
but i but but again i i feel the same
the same shifts that that you do um
talk to me about social media
and i mean i think a lot of us have seen
the social
dilemma and i'm not really talking about
the big brother aspect of it but
how has in in your view how has social
media changed
not the way kids interact but the way
adults
behave so i
look at social media as a symptom of low
confidence
inherent low confidence when when
confidence is low our decision making is
all about
me here now we don't plan
we don't look into the future we don't
have a great deal of regard for
others it's about me
not you um
and so i i look at social media as
really the perfect vehicle for a bunch
of
me here now thinking people to act
and communicate in me here now mode
and you know we have a whole
infrastructure for this you know we have
the
iphone we have we have we have developed
a
a network you know amazon delivering to
you at home
doordash delivering to you at home we we
have a
an incredible me here now economy
infrastructure
designed to satisfy your every need
you danielle just you can get whatever
you want
right now you know go to spotify go to
netflix
go to you know we don't we don't even
have to share a pot of coffee
just bring your pots so
so that we have we have
so satisfied the individual
that people see no need today to be part
of a collective
there's no need to
love your brother you know love your
neighbor be
part of a community yeah you know
i saw your pin tweet and you know with
reference to the k-shaped
recovery i mean this is this is the time
to
be charitable um but to your point
people need to be reminded and
i think that that is a that's a change
and and one of the terrible tragedies to
me of this this quarantining environment
is that those who are just
have been offended by this pandemic are
truly unseen today
people are not getting out into the
community
and are seeing the reality around them
they don't have to you know everything
is delivered
true it's just it's amazing to me that
and i'm the most conservative fiscally
conservative person
in the world but i i'm just i'm amazed
at our politicians
debating whether or not there should be
an extension
of the rental eviction moratorium i'm
like
who who are these god-like
entities who are talking about putting
single mothers
out of their homes in january
how could how could we even be a society
that contemplates
such an atrocity because we've elected
billionaires
we've elected into physicians of public
policy
the very wealthy and even they don't
seem satisfied with that you look at the
volume
of insider trading that goes on in
washington today
oh gosh but but i think that
because this rebound has so
benefited them they have none of the
sense of urgency
that existed in march it's not about
them
and and they have partisanized
i'm not sure that's a word but so
so democrats view the poor
as the rural poor that you know why
would we help them
republicans view the poor as the the
urban
poor why would we help them and
and the reality is poor is poor
it's a non-partisan experience right it
is
and sorry go ahead i'm just afraid that
that those at the top don't appreciate
that the most distressing divide is not
left right today
it's up down if the rural poor and the
urban poor
were to come together in america there'd
be a revolution
oh i have i i i can't um
it goes back to financial literacy it
really does
when we started depriving the average
american child
of a decent education that was that was
a moment
and there was a time that the democrats
were a party for the people and
there was a time that there were two
definitive parties
in america but it doesn't feel like that
anymore
now the environment is right for a third
party leader to come to the fore
a young charismatic individual who can
coalesce the left and the rights
along economic grounds as opposed to
ideological grounds
well if you throw rising interest rates
into the mix you'll get exactly what
you're talking about
exactly what you're talking about um
so if you if you had to look forward
um a few years
given where you started
do you think that there is and this has
always been something i have
hoped for and to see in my lifetime
but do you think that what we're going
to go through economically because i
don't think we have
yet because there's still this
confidence in the federal reserve
but do you think that there's a chance
that americans
the consumer ever goes back to being
not me here now not instant
gratification not living on credit not
getting everything that they want if
they have access
to that credit and i'm not talking about
the poor and i'm not talking about the
rich
i'm talking about the aspirational the
in the middle
the people who watch shows about buying
homes and fixing them up
and living that life but do you think
that
because i've i've the people who are
frozen
to use your term the people who who went
into hibernation
a lot of them have shifted how they
consume and that's going to be permanent
so the coronavirus has kind of been like
a great depression
moment but it's only for a small slice
of americans
but do you do you envision because if
you're talking about
a 40-year shift in the interest rate
regime that we've known for our entire
careers
do you think that that would change the
american consumer mindset
yes i do i think that
you are likely to see a
an environment where there is
savings before spending
and and that is going to be a function
of both
the supply and demand of consumer credit
that that culturally
more equity will be required
and and it will be a societal trend that
proves
is a virtue now if you think about it
that's a
that's an enormous supply and demand
suck between now and then
because you're telling us we can't pull
forward demand
we're going to have to push it back
while people save up
but the pulling forward has always been
a function of the falling interest rate
exactly exactly so
as interest rates rise and the cost of
goods goes up in the minds of the
consumer
and the lender you'll start to see
a a demand for more capital more capital
at corporate levels at individual levels
and so that the unwind
in this is incredibly painful
because it it hits you know we're going
to
turn you know a screw that's going
around really quickly this direction
stop it and turn it back the other way
yeah i mean you're you're talking about
a world that is genuinely foreign to
most
americans alive today
hard and it will transform
what what main street looks like
what the suburbs look like
the amount of of shopping
real estate that will have to be
repurposed
in the midst of this um not just because
of
you know amazon and the home delivery
aspect but just
a change in buying behavior more
fundamentally
you know this is this is a generation um
that doesn't want the stuff that our
generation wanted
they they look at the bird they look at
stuff as a burden
where to our generation it was evidence
of
success
interesting i mean i i can't imagine
that world and i've been writing about
getting to that world for a very long
time but i would like to think that
the silver lining maybe we can end on a
high note
would be education i think it's
education
i also think it's a sense of of
togetherness
that is reborn out of this
one of the things that i know from
studying confidence is that
we will come together first
as grassroots communities
and from that you will see an extension
of greater and
greater cohesiveness
and again i don't know who these new
community leaders will be
but i'm really excited for them because
they will have nothing to lose
and they will be coalescing around
common purpose around a need to be heard
a need to be seen
and and that's that next
wave is going to be incredibly powerful
in whatever direction it goes well i can
tell you just from
observation from some of the interns
that i've had
uh and and you're in you're in the
teaching world so you've seen generation
z
and they're nothing like millennials
they're extremely hard working and they
are more frugal
in the way they approach the world
and um and we could see something really
magnificent come from this uh
so i think that's i think that's
probably a good place
a good place to leave it peter because
that that's a high note
and um and i'm i'm halfway to a hundred
but i'm hoping that i'm not too old that
i can't in some way help participate
uh in it you do a great service
for everybody on on twitter uh i i
recommend
everybody should follow you just because
i i try and deliver an education
a lot of times there's volatility and
anger in it um
but no no partisanship on my feed and
you do the same thing
you you do a great service as well and
uh
i really appreciate your time today and
i look forward to talking to you next
year
likewise danielle it's been a lot of fun
thank you so much for asking me to call
in
absolutely take good care happy holidays
thank you
[Music]
you